dans la mer blanche près du cercle
arctique on retrouve la forteresse
monastique de ce love qui l'endroit est
isolé loin de tout paisible c'est pour
cela que des moines s'y sont installés
dès le xvème siècle mais la révolution
d'octobre est venue tout bouleverser les
moines de se love qui célèbre
régulièrement des messes à la mémoire
des 15 mille prisonniers qui ont trouvé
la mort ici dans le monastère a été
transformée en prison puis en camp de
travail pendant une trentaine d'années
un million de personnes ont été
emprisonnées dans cet archipel d'où
personne n'est arrivé à s'enfuir
l'enfant est resté sauvage est ici
déplacer tient de l' aventure au nord de
celui qui on retrouve cette petite
église qui fut aménagée en cachot
disciplinaire on y détenait dans des
conditions abjectes les prisonniers les
plus récalcitrants dans la forêt
environnante plusieurs croient témoigne
du sort réservé à de nombreux
prisonniers
le sol s'est effondré à plusieurs
endroits où se trouvent des fosses
communes
quand les restes désormais été trouvé il
y avait des trous de balles dans la
nuque
certaines personnes et il avait les
mains attachées au dos
c'est un coup de canon tirés de ce
croiseur aurora il ya cinq ans qui
devait changer le monde
lenny n'avait plus la tête d'une
insurrection visant à renverser le
gouvernement
bizouard formé après la démission du
tsar nicolas ii le coup de canon était
le signal pour des centaines de
militaires deux travailleurs
d'anarchistes pour qu'ils s'emparent du
siège du gouvernement
la révolution socialiste était en marche
[Musique]
dans les mois qui suivent lénine
commence à envoyer des opposants des
contre-révolutionnaires à soleuvre qui
staline qui lui succède décide de faire
de ce lieu bien centre d'expérimentation
un modèle qui sera utilisé à travers
toute l'union soviétique les goulags se
multiplient au fil des ans 18 millions
de personnes seront envoyés dans ces
camps de travail 4 millions de détenus
qui trouveront la mort
c'est pour cela qu'il n'y aura pas de
grande cérémonie de commémoration encore
mois de célébration de cette révolution
d'octobre
on organise des expositions dans des
musées des séminaires mais pas de
grandes manifestations
l'historienne arias et nina constate
malgré tout un regain de popularité pour
staline est le symbole de la force de
l'ordre
une forte volonté sur ses années pouvoir
totalitaire demeure une des périodes les
plus tragiques plus dramatiques de
l'histoire ce qui aide à redorer l'image
de staline c'est que sous vladimir
poutine on mettre en veilleuse cette
révolution d'octobre
on célèbre plutôt chaque année le 9 mai
en grande pompe la victoire russe sur le
nazisme et si staline qui était à la
tête du pays à l'époque
les routes cov dirige le centre de
sondage levada wassim prosoft agde à
seulement 8 % de la population avec une
opinion positive de staline en 1989
maintenant ça change peu à peu la
propagande a d'abord présenté staline
comme étant l'homme de la victoire dans
cette guerre mais aussi de la
modernisation de la construction du
grand état russe denisov poutine se
posent en héritiers de cette gloire de
cette victoire dans la grande guerre
patriotique
ce qui est important c'est l'ordre
pendant ces années pouvoir de staline
son attitude politique a géré le pays
clé dans ce sens poutine est l'héritier
du grand staline
peu à peu des statues de staline
réapparaissent dans le pays comme ici au
musée d'histoire militaire à moscou
mais ceux qui refusent d'oublier les
goulags et leurs millions de morts
peuvent aller se recueillir devant cette
pierre transporter de ce loft qui jusqu
en plein coeur de moscou
et si raymond st-pierre radio canada à
moscou